We have a voicemail number, which I invite
you to call anytime of day.
If it's three 20 in the morning and you decide
you want to leave me 14 voicemails as somebody
did last night, go ahead and do it.
Just, you know, if they're three minutes long
each, don't expect them to make it onto the
show.
Here is a voicemail about the callers that
we get on the show.
It's not particularly charitable to the callers.
Take a listen.
Hi David.
This is Peter from China.
Uh, look, I don't have a bone to pick with
you today.
I just want to praise you for your amazing
patients.
Some of the coal is you get to your show,
I complete morons and you, you, you stick
out and you show amazing patients with, with
them.
Um, if it was me, I would've hung up on them
a long time ago.
So good on you.
Good on you.
You've got amazing patients.
Keep up the good work.
I love your shirt.
Yeah.
Well listen, uh, the, the patience and attention
span gene runs in the Pacman family.
Um, and I, I do think that that is maybe part
of why I am able to, uh, entertain not only
a 14 consecutive three minute voicemails,
sometimes on the voicemail line, but also
sometimes callers whose, um, thesis statement
is not particularly well formed and they are
sort of working through it with me.
I guess.
I, I'm, I'm trying to be polite here, but
yes, we welcome all sorts of different callers
on the program.
I don't care about your gender, I don't care
about your religion.
I don't care about your sexual orientation,
country of origin, country of residency, political
orientation, IQ.
We, it just, everybody is allowed to call
in and uh, we will, uh, be respectful and
polite to everybody until such time that they
are not respectful to me.
And that's when I start to get a little bit
upset.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about New York immediately having
second thoughts just days after ending cash
bail.
It's weird what's going on there.
We're also going to talk about a lawsuit from
a transgender teen over a birth certificate.
The right is having a field day with a story.
And we will also talk about Facebook banning
deep fake videos, which is funny because if
the videos are good enough that you can't
tell that it's a deep fake, how can you ban
it?
Because you don't know that that's what it
is.
Anyway, we'll talk about that in the future
of deep fake technology.
On today's bonus show in mere moments, how
to access the bonus show two ways.
Number one, become a member@joinpacmandotcomthatwillgiveyouinstantaccessoptiontobecomeapatronforatleastfivebucksamonthatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
I will speak to you then or otherwise on tomorrows
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].